King zidian and he played It Against the
World Champ himself
what do you think of that James it's
very risky because it is strategically
tough opening when it's donya's bread
and butter that's right it is and I
think you know he's gonna go with his
best and I would do the same thing I
would go with my absolute best would I
like that's in fast time controls best
right because as time controls is
different you know in the classical game
like this might be tough or way tougher
to play this opening um with Supply
pieces but here I mean time is low
things can happen and as kings Indians
are very sharp you know how he plays
them he knows the ins and outs so I
think it's a good practical choice
yeah I'm with you and I think that for
Donya he really does not want to lose
this game both personally and for the
team Magnus Carlson on a bit of a
rampage right now if you can slow him
down that would be great for your team's
chances heading into this round the
chess bras were up five to three so if
Donna can at least draw against Magnus
and the rest of the team could score
some points they'll be right back in
this but the problem with the king's
Indian is this is not a tactical King's
Indian where you have F5 and it's a
positional one and this bishop on G7 not
the best piece at least for the time
being and look at Don you go Queen A5
I'm already looking can't I play Rook B1
and B4 A3 and B4 should I take the time
to defend this Pawn on e4 because it is
under attack as the knights either is
pinned diet standpoint I mean he has
Knight takes E4 uh definitely coming so
Knight to Chief three okay cool cool
defends it understandable does black
send it here is it one of those
positions where you just toss your oppon
up the board I don't like B5 because
all right you gotta take with the pawn
that's the poor annoying part B5 looks
so nice though so King's indian-esque so
maybe go Bishop D7 to play B5
yeah Bishop B7 seems calmer I feel like
there's some shirt game maybe it's
Hikaru against grashook that was in this
type of position and I think white can
play Rook B1 now and B4 it might have
been from the Grand Prix the Phoenix
Grand Prix that Hikaru won to qualify
for the candidates wow you play Bishop
C7 too as well for 57 to try to play
this B5 move you know James you won
there it is you know I actually do
control the sort of the Palm break of F5
I can play F4 I have an open file now
open B file slightly but I mean you
could argue that black actually could be
slightly better from a human standpoint
I like what you're saying and I think
for Magnus at some point he may consider
the move C4 uh because in the end game
or at least in the queenless position
the king can happily sit in the center
the bishop on G7 is the worst minor
piece on the board whereas the bishop on
E3 is healthy and staring in both
directions so I do like this uh position
for Magnus I think his minor pieces are
better he has more space but it's a
solid position for black and the move G5
it does allow Dania at the right moment
to open up some of his pieces but look
at Magnus confidently pressing forward
here saying go for F6 I'm not worried
about that move in the slightest I'll
just play H4 and reinforce my Pawn in
the center here again that Bishop is
extremely bad you take with the pawn
here look at the dark Square Bishop we
have a h file that's open I think it's a
clear plan for white try to double on
the H file exactly
it can move around like this but it's
not going anywhere this bishop we're on
C5 oh I can't cheat and do that now
we're talking white would be happy right
black would be happy rather but that
Bishop cannot get out your pawns are all
in the way so Dania you might just be
playing safe chess and say you're not
going to make any progress there are no
queens in the board there's no checking
attack I could always slide my Bishop
back where is this Knight going where is
magnus's Knight aiming for is it this
square is it this square or maybe F4
many questions to answer that's actually
Correy I'm trying to figure out what is
this plan F4 will probably be it is it's
just a huge blunder why would you we can
open up the position King in the center
the pawn on e4 will be hanging The
Bishop's nice now so F4 will be a fatal
blunder uh so the bishop on G7 clearly
the worst piece Magnus trying to improve
his Knight Donya trying to prove his as
well and I don't think Knight C5 is a
good move here I would snap that off
immediately I wouldn't even take a
second to think you play 95 I take it I
take it
you take with the d-pod I have a pass
Pawn is protected right he played Knight
C5 wow okay let's see if Magnus grabs
that because if you take with the B Pawn
an open B file should be good for the
Rook though the F2 Pawn maybe is a
little bit tender as Rook can always
slide up one square to defend I really
like mag's position but I also feel like
Dania yeah he's just solid here he's
definitely solid yeah he's there's like
there's no breakthrough this he's
definitely very solid and I like this
about dinos position very great choice
or something I was looking I was like
how is it you didn't even move yet right
so
it's you know I think it's very equal
very nice from uh this bishop is so
strong I think I see why Magnus did not
take the Knight it's protecting G5 it's
protecting F2 so there's no threats
anywhere in the position because the
bishop holds everything down the
position is saying that what is this
evil bar talking about I'm wondering the
same thing because if you take this
knight ever this G5 Pawn is in some
trouble uh so I'm wondering where the
tactics are you see the eval bar being
this High there must be some winning
Tech if this is let's analyze a little
bit here and if Bishop takes Knight
okay so it is Bishop takes it might be
Knight takes D6 like something like this
right oh oh it is oh my goodness it's
mates
it's mate the two Rooks it's by
themselves with this Pawn get out of
here it's gross
I guess King F6 only moving Rook f8 is
easy just me and me thank you very much
bro
oh my gosh so the threat is you take
this Knight you then go and take this D6
Pawn
oh God man you lost the Rook I was
wondering like what if he takes with the
pawn then what if he takes with like the
bee Pawn you still do Knight D6 what if
he takes with the c Pawn then
there's no C Pawn I mean sorry
[Laughter]
that one's a new one that's a new move
oh no no oh he took it to Rook yeah what
what was DC was DC wrong too I think DC
you just go F4 and if it takes E5 Jesus
bro that's just yeah that's a wrap oh my
goodness yeah it's not about the
quantity it's about the quality and we
see how strong those pawns would be in
the center and whoa Magnus players F4
yeah I mean a steel
um
yeah he's gonna put Knight 66 next or
Knight D4 Knight to E6 something like
that
yeah it's tough that's tough found this
broke through here break through here
wait but he oh he takes look at that
that's Carlson is so good that he could
have taken on D6 right away and he says
Ah let me throw an F4 just to free up my
next Pawn uh just in case I need it jeez
now he pushes the pawn through that is
gross man Knight to D6 is on the board
man he was holding like a beast bro I
mean I thought it was I thought he was
gonna get a draw I'm not even gonna lie
here I really thought this was going to
be a drop
in a very solid position
yeah two but the past pawns now are too
strong and Dania knows it uh the good
news for Donya even if he goes down in
this game is his Cobra teammates are
doing quite well I see a Wonder Liang is
taking down ariantari that's huge news
for the Cobra fans because if if the
chess bra scored enough points in this
round the match would be over but
they're not going to get to that three
and a half that gives a fourth and final
game and we've seen Magnus Carlson top
right his pawns reaching E6 the next
punk you go to D6 and the pawns are
gonna keep rolling up the board I think
that this one's just about done with uh
meanwhile I see Arena Crush she's about
to make a draw against Rosman Pro 2. so
that leaves a Wonder Liang to the task
of taking down orientare
yeah it's gonna be this is tough here
what is that I mean it's like I don't
even know what the match score is it's
like oh he's he no he's winning no
they're winning over here what is is
back and forth they're swinging on each
other and there's a draw there uh
Rossman got a draw nice we had a creeper
yeah nice okay did they split this round
I think actually the cobras are gonna
take it if uh because Brian Jacobson won
for the cobras and if Wonder Liang is
able to win his game and he does have a
huge advantage against our antari he's
up in exchange for no compensation that
one's over then the cobras will take
round three two and a half to one and a
half
okay all right Chad
it's a lot going on here yeah he's not
in peace now if you take this the king
G7 all right there's some hope with the
past pawns over here
yeah yeah no no play for you
yeah
no he's not even a check
and that covers the check over here
Rook takes B6 yeah and it's coming back
this way two seconds one second he moves
two seconds and if Rook F7 is Rook takes
H7 oh gross
Magnus Carlson
just a bully at this point poor Dania I
feel for him and after rook's trade the
Knight is able to come back and stop on
The Rook goes up and now you're just
down a minor piece for no compensation
so uh this one is all Magnus Carlson and
I think dinos about to resign in a
couple turns
tougher done yeah tough form at least we
get a big raid from James Marriott
thanks for the raid here wow huge raid
raid raid thanks for the rage
yeah
love that love love to see the new uh
fans coming in watching this action
you're probably your favorite educator
Daniel naroditski he is oh my gosh
another Fork Magnus just goes for every
tactic in the position Donya has to
resign he'll learn from the game but
Magnus Carlson is a monster he has not
stopped in the Pro chess League thus far